he dished it off to clint right to send
things basically into overtime which was
key but
he said point blank we don't come back
in that game against detroit if trey
young doesn't turn into trey young down
the stretch
and there he goes rookie jayden
mcdaniels missing the three-pointer
walks by one trey on the lob and cabela
answers
22 19. edwards what up compelling
at the rim no young fella four blocks
for clint
trey just walks right nice and easy
and just let it go i mean look at this
easy does it lob to clint yeah you know
he didn't even throw it down the heart
he just pushed it in he's like you know
this is too easy they're not going away
the hawks
had their chance to kind of put them
away this quarter
[Applause]
collins reed went down no
call trey lets it go swish
inside of the final four minutes of the
third quarter as trey brings it over
step back three he is failing it right
now
hey female 40 for trey is a two-way
player last july
reed out of lsu and another rejection
for capella his eighth
he does a good job of getting to the
basket but that's an
easy block 99-78
oh no another no no no no number nine
for clint capela
collins back to trey corner three good
he's got 43. another unbelievable
offensive night for trey young
he has had the stroke going big time